friedrich wilhelm hegel was already
reprimanded several times during his student days
for playing excessive cards and drinking
too much red wine
he is undoubtedly one of the most
unconventional today one would probably
say the coolest thinker of all it is
also said he
discovered the world spirit in addiction that is of course
unfair firmly  is his discovery of
the dimension of becoming in
all its scope is still relevant today
and one of the most important discoveries
of philosophy he is the charles
darwin of philosophers because everything as
hegel really is in constant
motion human life has
just as much a process character as nature
and  history man comes
into the world as an infant grows into a child into a
young person and into an adult and
also the history of
mankind progresses from the simplest beginnings
one epoch followed another
if we speak casually today of the zeitgeist
which also applies to every
e  discovery back that every era has its
own penetrating spirit
this zeitgeist or as hegel would also
say the world spirit shows itself in people
's respective convictions
of morality justice
art music architecture
but he is not satisfied with that he
makes a second one  more important
discovery the different spirit forms
and epochs so edel claims
are not randomly strung together
but follow a logical
principle of movement of the so-called famous
dialectics the pendulum of history
swings sometimes in this sometimes in the other
direction but nevertheless
mankind slowly and inexorably steers towards
its greatness  aim yes the book rules
the 60 minutes explains using the best
quotes how the dialectic and thus the
motor of human history works in
detail many books
claim
to be able to explain the difficult philosopher hegel well
i would say this book does it
we  Sure the exciting questions that will emerge from
his fascinating
philosophy I think all answered where
does the story end are we just
spectators or players
who or what is this world spirit and
what is the meaning of life what use
is hegel's discovery today a lot of
fun